bad decisions have led to tens of
thousands of
unnecessary deaths so we all needed the
government to succeed
in this pandemic and that's why
supporting the government during the
pandemic
was the right thing to do for the
country
but the truth is the tories have got
virtually every big decision wrong
either in substance
in timing or both
people have died tragically
more will do so it's possible
to forgive an unprecedented situation
if ministers hearts are in the right
place
and they're trying their best but we've
seen
chaos confusion and cronyism at the
heart of government
and we had another example of it this
weekend
when the prime minister and the
chancellor claimed
that they had miraculously been selected
for a trial
so they could avoid isolation isolation
that
hundreds of thousands of the rest of us
have dutifully
taken with family events cancelled
businesses having to close
and workers going without pay johnson
and sunak's attempts to dodge isolation
were crass and they were insensitive
at a time when we need to maintain
confidence in self-isolation
parents workers and businesses will be
wondering what on earth is going on
in downing street and that's why i've
written to the prime minister
because there are i'm afraid too many
unanswered
questions the prime minister's claim
that he
did look briefly at the idea of taking
part in the pilot scheme
that rides coach and horses through the
claim that boris johnson and rishi sunak
have been magically selected for the
trial it is
completely inconsistent with the downing
street press release yesterday morning
saying that they were participating in
the trial of the pilot
so let's be clear boris johnson and
rishi sunak
only went into isolation because
they were busted we've seen once again
their instincts on show one rule for
them
another rule for the rest of us the
government needs to publish all the
details of how ministers
deemed themselves eligible for this
scheme at a time when the public
have not had the same access to it and
there are more questions arising
from the prime minister isolating at
checkers
did boris johnson travel to his country
retreat
after the health secretary first had
symptoms
you'd have thought that given the amount
of money spent on refurbishing downing
street
he'll be happy staying there as the
chancellor has
but we know that the prime minister
likes to look for a loophole
we need to know when the prime minister
was contacted
and where he was when he was contacted
we know that
michael gove tried this ploy back in may
after the champions league
final will the government now release a
full list of conservative ministers
who've benefited from the trial and
avoided self-isolation
many businesses and individuals have
struggled
to do the right thing and follow the
rules they would have benefited
from this policy tube workers on london
underground
which is now facing staff shortages due
to self-isolation
leading to delays and to cancellations
they could have benefited from the but
contrary to government claims
transport for london has not yet been
confirmed
as a participant in the scheme
this is just the tip of the iceberg
there are hundreds of thousands of
people who've been forced
to miss family events close businesses
and go without pay because they have
done
the right thing and yet ministers
have played the system children sent
home from school
after positive cases in their bubble
nhs staff working overtime to cover
staff absences
and businesses struggling to run a
normal service
due to their employees self-isolating
these people deserve an immediate answer
from ministers
about the cabinet's participation in
this scheme
this cannot go on the public need clear
leadership at this time
not this hypocritical way of trying to
do things that just
undermine confidence in the rules and
put lives at risk
we can't afford to get this wrong the
price we'll all pay
is too high so i call on the prime
minister
to join me in urging everyone including
his ministers and his mates
to continue to follow the rules on
self-isolation
the government urgently needs to change
course
drop plans to lift all restrictions
and rebuild public faith in the
isolation system
they've undermined at the same time
the chaotic incompetent way boris
johnson
conducts himself is dangerous
it makes for bad government and it has
deadly consequences for the british
public
wave one more people died
and more economic damage was done
because the prime minister was too slow
to act
stuck at checkers when he should have
taken charge
wave two more people died and
more economic damage was done because of
boris johnson and rishi sunak's decision
to ignore the science and delay a
lockdown
in the autumn this deadly era
was made worse by a failed christmas
gamble
that caused heartache to many
and wave three more people died
and more economic damage was done
just as the nhs and the british public
had given us
light at the end of the tunnel with the
vaccine program
the prime minister threw the country
into chaos once again
by delaying border controls and allowing
what we're calling the johnson variant
into the country and now today
a reckless free-for-all his
character causes chaos
his leadership causes mayhem
labor does not support the government's
plan
lifting all restrictions in one go
is reckless and doing so when the
johnson variant
is clearly out of control risks a summer
of chaos we're heading now
for an nhs summer crisis
we will always support jobs and
livelihoods
but johnson's recklessness risks
plunging us back
into restrictions again freedom day
is just the latest in a long list of
slogans
not backed up by policy this will not be
freedom day
for the hundred thousand people per day
catching kovid
and the millions more being asked to
isolate
it's far from freedom day for the 3.7
million
clinically vulnerable who once again
been ignored
the government has once again lost
control of the virus
and lost public trust in its messaging
they need to think again
on their reckless plan before
it's too late thank you i'll now take
some questions thank you